to people when I censored The Osbournes
are still with me live from their home
in Los Angeles they've got a brilliant
new podcast it's basically the band have
got back together uh I listened to the
first couple of episodes absolutely
brilliant hilarious sharp outrageous
funny all the things you'd expect from
Mills balls let's take a look
hi I'm Kelly drag
and I'm the boss Aussie yeah Osborne
podcast uh and we're back after a
five-year Hiatus on the internet
conspiracy theorists are always talking
about ah there's sex sex Cults in in L.A
have you ever been invited to a satanic
sex cult never I've never seen
one of you Kelly I've never even been
invited to a sex party
I need to go to a happier place I feel
real romantic just go to bed darling
that right there was an invitation to a
sex cult wasn't it
scary
um
stuff that's happening in the news uh
Russell Brand obviously you know major
celebrity figure on both sides of the
pond for a long time now accused of rape
and sexual abuse and a big investigation
by the Sunday Times and channel 4
dispatches Sharon what do you make of
this story you know Russell Brand
yeah I on but I you know would
look being a woman when I hear these you
know cases where women have been abused
and taken advantage of I automatically
go to to the woman's side because I I
love women I care about them and so I'm
already on the women's side but you know
you want to know details you want to
know everything involved the only thing
I can say about Russell Brand is the two
things that I don't like was when he
um spoke about uh
one of them is a very good friend of
ours
um Kimberly Stewart about what he'd done
to Kimberly Stewart in front of her
father well I was there I was actually
there you know so Bob gildoff well I was
there oh he was well I was there when he
boasted about uh having slept with
Kimberly Stewart and Rod Stewart was
there and Rod Stewart was the GQ Awards
2006 and Rod Stewart went up on stage
and absolutely took him down and he
called him out and he said you do not
boast about something when you haven't
done it and Rod Afters was telling me he
was very pleased to have put him in his
place and he said you know it was really
disgraceful so I think with Russell
Brown there's always been a lot of
embellishment as well as the boasting
yeah and it's um you just don't do that
to people's families when you when that
father is in the room he's done it twice
now and that's the thing that I you know
sticks with me but this situation he's
going through right now I you know I
don't know details so I can't I mean
Jack it seems to me we've been through
32 times up a lot of bad people have had
their due come up and some people were
unfairly caught up in that and you know
exonerated
um I do believe in due process for
everyone in these situations it seems to
me that until you actually have the
police look at this properly it's unfair
I mean at the moment he's been canceled
left right and centered by everybody and
everything and vilified and chained
because everyone's assuming every word
of the allegations are true but they
remain at the moment allegations
yeah and I was going to say just that
you know it's you know we've all known
Russell you know going on 20 years and
um you know you'd like to sit there and
go like no that I don't I don't see him
you know he's done some vulgo outrageous
crazy things but you never want to
assume that someone you know and is a
friend or you know an acquaintance is is
capable of that but you you know I I'm
we got to see you know we saw it with
the Danny Masterson situation I mean I I
was a personal friend of Danny's like I
had been to his house I'd played poker
with him I'd you know I I actually knew
some of the the victims and so it that
story was like oh my God like this is it
it's when when you know someone and then
they get found guilty it definitely
shakes your foundation because you never
know what happens
um honestly let me pivot to some
something else which is the American
election coming next year could end up
being Biden V Trump again Biden at the
moment looking extremely old and frail
uh Trump all pumped up as he normally is
storming away with the Republican
nomination do you think we may see
Donald Trump back in the White House
unfortunately yes
because I mean it
every every time he gets arrested
he's the popularity rise but I was
saying I think I was having him arrested
and yeah it's incredible I mean
everything arrested in the mug shots it
well it's funny it's funny you mentioned
more fuel it's funny you mentioned mug
shots because I did a bit of research
you'll be pleased to hear before you
guys came on and I was trying to think
of has there ever been a more iconic mug
shot than Donald Trump's and look what I
found
no
Ozzy Osbourne in Memphis for I think it
was intoxication in a public place
Aussie do you remember that
yeah yeah I do
what do you think pee on the police car
Peter and the police zones
I was I was asleep in them in this
Central divide on a freeway Pittsburgh
and all these cars was imposed and I
thought I need to take a pee not the
best idea
I felt around in the darkness there was
a car there I started to play and as
soon as I did this blue light on the top
flashing chairs your ass is going to
jail and when you when you did the mug
shot Aussie what is it like to do a mug
shop
well he's down there again
can you even remember doing it
okay oh yeah
yeah and Sharon I want to talk to you my
lord Sharon I want to talk to you about
Ashton Kutcher because you were asked
who's the rudiest celebrity you've ever
met and you suddenly said Ashton
goodshire but you haven't explained why
so why
um he came on it on the on a show I was
on the talk and I had to introduce him
so I introduced him and you know Mia I'm
terrible with names and I didn't
pronounce his name properly so in the
break
I apologize for not getting his name
um correct and he turned around and he
said to me now let's go back here
because he'd known me for many years I'd
worked on his shows the whole family had
when we were all at MTV at the same time
and he looked at me and he goes who are
you what even do you do wow what's your
thing
and so I looked at him and I just said
you know you little and so after
that it just it just stayed with me and
um you know as I said he's a dastardly
little man but it was funny though
because mum made that comment and then
the next day it came out that he'd
written the letters to the judge and I
think everyone thought it was because
mum knew that yeah no I'd give you like
weeks prior yeah it's very funny it just
coincided at the same time yeah we're
getting to the end of it's been great to
catch up with you guys thank you so much
for doing this Aussie people are going
to ask are you going to be able to tour
again what's your answer to that
uh I'd like to say yes but I don't know
at this point
how difficult has it been for you as one
of the great rock stars this country has
ever produced certainly one of the great
stage artists how hard is it be not to
be able to perform
well it's kind of just well it's the
only thing I know what to do really
you know sometimes I can't live with it
and I can't live at the same time I
can't live without it you know oh Mr
Diggs almost a comrade and laughs and
the road the audience especially
but um
I don't know what to say
well I think I think let me do the
talking I just want to say I I think on
behalf of everybody who loves music and
loves proper rock stars I think we would
all absolutely love to see you back on
that stage one more time I know I much
you've missed it it must be so difficult
to have gone through what you've been
through but Aussie I gotta say there
have been times of the last few years
when I wasn't sure if I would see you
for an interview like this again and I'm
just so I feel so happy to see you there
with your family
um all together thank you I gotta say
you look great mate and I know you've
been through hell and I'm delighted I'm
delighted the spinal stuff it seems
you've come through that and the
Parkinson's is under control and you're
looking good and it's great to see you
and it's and it's great Sharon I think
for you to see your old man there
looking alive and well and kicking well
you know it is you know it I just wish
last night we all got some sleep yeah
last night by the way our fire alarm
went off five times during the night
and the rest yeah so we're all like
zombies today things are never calm and
quiet in the Osborne Family never never
never and now we've been joined by the
only creatures ever the only creatures
madder than their owners are these dogs
but I remember the one that you had on
America's Got Talent was it Minnie the
dog on AGT Minnie what a fabulous but
she was like Sharon Small but very
dangerous
guys we've run out of time thank you all
of you jack Kelly Sharon great to see
you and I hope to see you in the flesh
soon you take care thank you very much